hello freak [ __ ] you know I didn't
know you used to fight until after the
last time I did the podcast I just
thought you got it worked out a lot and
just really liked mixed martial arts in
combat well I never fought in mixed
martial arts cuz I wasn't around but uh
kickboxing yeah I did that yeah cuz I
remember to see or something somebody
said oh you talk about Rogan like that
he'll kick you and your [ __ ] you know
what and then I looked up Rogan
kickboxing like what the [ __ ] she was
kicking the [ __ ] out of a bat yeah yeah
how that feel meant to hit somebody it
feels weird the bag Oh pack is easy yeah
bags on her back was the last time you
hit somebody in anger or in competitions
been a long [ __ ] time anger Oh
neither one there's one longer yeah
angry and anger is probably high school
competitions lost 22 or something that
that was a Taekwondo tournament I was 19
then oh and that was you yeah those need
to walk if you kick somebody the body
like that it's spinning back kick to the
body so much bulletproof doesn't matter
that thing that's just moral protection
oh man you so what was your at that
point when you saw him laying down he's
dead the news dawn but I'm not dead and
you know what you take it he's not
getting out was it what yeah you have to
walk away and like make it look like
it's no big deal that is how my thought
process was don't get excited
make it look like this is what I'm gonna
do to everybody just relax just walk off
and have everybody so nervous that you
don't even care like this is just a
normal thing for you you kick people
that go unconscious they fall down they
can't get up that you got to have that
people because you're in a tournament so
you're gonna be fighting about and then
watch it yeah you might have to fight
three or four times a day
who was there rooting for you just my
teammates guys that I trained with yeah
yeah it doesn't even seem like even more
I watch that doesn't really feel like me
so long ago
here well not I mean that I mean I also
have a head protector on the back of my
hand they would wear these head
protectors you could wear a full one
that covers your whole head like over
your ears or you wear one that's just
the back of your head which is really
just there so when you get knocked out
yeah it doesn't [ __ ] bounce off the
ground yeah because we were fighting on
a basketball court if you look at that
that's just a wood floor [ __ ] yeah
there's a lot of that fun on a hockey
rink once where they put a plastic sheet
down on a hockey rink so it was uh not
the ice but the cement underneath the
hockey rink
so we're basically fighting on cement so
the 80s were terrible it's like an awful
[ __ ] up knocked out and bounce their
head off the ground
jeez I saw a lot of that yeah not good
and for no money that's the thing
there's no future no future and no money
for the love of the game well I guess it
prepares you for life and also you
wanted to find out I wanted to find out
how I would do you know I wanted to find
out what it would be like to compete
under high stress situations like
worrying about someone kicking you in
the face yeah I'm I'm glad that most
people can't kick somebody in the face
so I'm glad that's whenever I go to a
UFC fight or MMA I just whenever
somebody gets kicked in the face I'm I
mean if I got kicked them faked have you
so disappointed it's not good it's not
it looks it looks crazy yeah it's
terrible for you the thing is more
people can kick people in the face now
that I think in any of the time in human
history I think there's a lot of [ __ ]
people they can kick people in the face
now because of watching MMA and the
Internet in classes yeah training I
think more people training now than than
ever before for sure there's way more
people that can strangle people than
ever
oh yeah 100% because the choke is easier
to learn no it's just more people are
doing jujitsu than any other time in
history like before like in my early
martial arts days there was no one that
was doing grappling really like I
wrestled in high school and then there
was no like jujitsu classes there was
like you could take judo like there was
judo but there was very
- you like actual like submission
grappling schools or anything like that
even nationwide there was a small
handful nobody knew what the [ __ ] they
were doing now everywhere you look
there's a judge it's at school like I
was down in San Diego just San Diego
alone which is not a big city they must
have a hundred jujitsu schools just in
San Diego [ __ ] it's crazy
you